beide studieren und haben sich auf eine
party kennengelernt und doch was ist
christian stolz an rebecca alles klar
liebe leute was gibt es schöneres als
einen anderen menschen in seinem leben
zu haben mit dem man sein eigenes leben
teilen kann der ein selbst genauso liebt
wie man ihn liebt mit dem man gemeinsam
die zeit verbringen kann und auch das
einmal den lachs verstecken und
gemeinsame urlaube vertrauen die familie
des anderen kennen lernen so stellen
sich viele leute in deutschland eine
beziehung vor machen aber dabei auch
wenn sie gerade selbst in einer
beziehung sind einen kapitalen fehler
denn ihre beziehung ist nicht gecheckt
nicht gecheckt weil das oberste amt und
die oberste instanz für die begutachtung
von der qualität von beziehungen in
deutschland immer noch was ist leute
genau der prosieben taff pärchen check
über diese etwas besondere idee von dem
fernsehformat habe ich schon mal video
gemacht jetzt kommt heute der zweite
teil zu einer weiteren folge und ja wir
schauen direkt mal ein so eine gute
laune badespaß in einem freibad mal
brühl treten drei paare an um
herauszufinden wer von ihnen sich am
besten kennt das ist soweit erst mal die
allgemeine idee von dem pärchen check
leute wären natürlich langweilig für uns
als zuschauer wenn es in den pagerank
darum gehen will sollte sich sich zeigen
wie gut sie sich kennen nein es geht
natürlich auch darum dass wirklich hier
massive queens momente produziert werden
hat sich auch der ein anderer freund
geisteskrank blamiert ich würde euch
dazu ist noch nicht zu viel verraten
leute aber ihr in dem friedhof was ich
halt übersprungen ab gibt es diese eine
szene ihr schaut euch das mal an ihr
könnt ihr schon denken worum es geht
leute ist die freundin werden gleich in
diese kabinen gehen dann werden die
männer erfassten wer die eigene freundin
ist ja ja und das sind die pärchen
rebecca und christian sind seit
anderthalb jahren zusammen beide
studieren und haben sich auf einer party
kennengelernt der christian will dass
die leiter guck mal erträgt einfach eine
uhr und ein lederarmband am selben abend
dass das finde ich war oder habe ich das
habe ich in der form glaube ich auch
noch nicht gesehen dass man an einer
hand so eine uhr treten dann der anderen
und lederarmband okay aber erst komplett
beide studieren und haben sich auf einer
party kennen gelernt geduld und toleranz
sind die dinge die sie an ihm schätzt
leute klingt aber auch bisschen soll
also ich weiß ich weiß es nicht wissen
es auch nicht zu negativ auslegen leute
aber könnte auch bisschen so klingen als
wir sie bisher in einer von der schweren
sorte oder depressiv das falsch also
wenn sie sagt geduld und toleranz
dann wird die geduld und toleranz ja
auch erst einmal getestet oder und auf
was ist christian stolz an rebecca
[Musik]
christian geil christian ist bewusst
dass hier gerade im fernsehen
ausgestrahlt wird
digger allein sechseinhalb millionen
aufrufe auf youtube ok deine freundin
sagt dass sie an der geduld und deine
ruhe schätzt und toleranz und was sagst
du
christian das kannst du dir insgeheim
denken also die sagen und das ist unser
zweites paar menschen sagen wir kennen
sich seit der fünften klasse die seele
aber auch wirklich aus als wäre er
achten muss ich schon sagen die sind
leute wenn ich die sehen nicht
volljährig aus oder typ dass man diese
nicht völlig aus wie als wenn wir vor
einem jahr hat es dann auf einmal klick
gemacht der kfz-mechatroniker weiß was
er seiner freundin hat achtung jetzt
kommt wird der wert du sagst brüste oder
hinter wir sind eben nationalen
fernsehen okay gesagt hätte irgendwas
sagt etwas tiefgründiges malabo da guck
mal das bisschen schlauer
wobei man muss ja auch sagen die ersten
beiden waren ja das ist so stumpf leute
ich nehme es einfach schon so hin und
kommentiert es aber sondern aber die
ersten beiden wandert da war sie auch so
jaja meine brüste das ist mein größter
vorzug als persönlicher mensch findet
kein wort aber egal
das war keine liebe ist guck mal leute
so geht das jungs da draußen ist und das
doch smith alter verstehen was ich meine
so man muss ja nicht gleich wenn schon
nicht die eigene freundin weil sie es
gewohnt ist dann allein 600 millionen
auf youtube blamieren
so wie christian mit der tür ins haus
hätte lieber so machen das dritte
paralleles und bianca die 18 jährige
studentin und der 20-jährige
auszubildende sind seit einem jahr
zusammen und haben sich auch auf einer
party kann ja ok an der stelle muss
jetzt mal kritik aussprechen dann
eintraf war der schott gerade eben nötig
diese aufgabe gerade im wadi war das
wirklich nötig war das nötig um an der
stelle die die qualität der beziehung
von diesen beiden jungen menschen
hervorzukehren gut ja wenn man muss aber
auch sagen die sich auch schon ein
bisschen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
jünger als ich bin ja 24 leute die keine
ahnung was ist wahrscheinlich so um die
18 also die ersten beiden war ein
bisschen älter die letzten beiden
pärchen dagegen bisschen jünger so das
argument so jung wie kann so ihre farben
bei den klamotten abstimmen
ich will auch gar nichts zu sehen geben
dass seine drei verliebte paare mal
sehen wie gut sie sich kennen
auch körperlich ja ich werde auf jeden
fall ihre körperteile unter tausenden
frauen unterscheiden können
jetzt sind wir jetzt hier würde man ihr
alter geht er gott er ist doch so stumpf
alter ja das ist es nachdem schon
angedeutet
so sieht das am ende aus wasserliesch
also alle freundin von dem so eine
kabine reinkommen dass die wahl komplett
begraben
die mädchen gehen in die kabinen und wir
testen wie gut die jungs die körper
ihrer freundinnen wirklich kennen durch
den öffnungen in den kabinen müssen die
uns den body ihre freundin ertasten was
kriegen die noch mal dafür weil ich
dachte man am anfang gesagt dass sie
eine reise dafür bekommen und also finde
ich echt lecker wird oder also für eine
dafür dass man mit seinem partner eine
reise gewinnen kann so was machen
vor laufender kamera vor
millionenpublikum irgendwie von üblichen
fremden angefasst zu werden
das ist sie nicht klassische ellbogen zu
investieren der stelle genau wie mache
jetzt hier den körper test um zu gucken
wie gut unsere teilnehmer die ellbogen
ihre eigenen partnerin kennt die
ellbogen ja als erogene zone er wirklich
am intensivsten berührt werden okay okay
jetzt sind jetzt richtig erraten aber
wirklich geschrumpft dinge als man in
die hand auch vollkommen
unterschiedliche körpertypen oder kann
man sich so bisschen dünner dies zum
beispiel auch dann aber auch so mega
sportlich findet dann die jetzt hier
dagegen ist hat schon viel kurve gerannt
als die anderen beiden wenn du die drei
mädels folge sehen das erkennt ein
blinder mit krückstock oder wer jetzt
wäre es doch nicht die eigene freundin
seien aber nein leute
nein wir wollen in diesem fernsehformat
menschen sich anfassen und das kind so
nicht einmal kurz durch gewechselt dann
ist eines
drei der 20 jährige azubi scheint die
streicheleinheiten an anderen frauen zu
genießen
quint leute es ist nicht der pärchen
check wenn nicht bei der freundin von
einem ihr völlig fremden 20 jährigen
azubi abgewatscht wird man kann als
pärchen nicht gecheckt werden wenn nicht
ein wildfremder mensch die eigene
freundin fast das gehört dazu nur so
kann man die beziehung testen
für die rote kabine und tatsächlich auch
bianca und dennis bekommen einen punkt
okay was hat jetzt ihr bauch pierce mit
27 punkten kommen
aber egal wer also wirklich
kameraführung findet ihr diesen also ist
schon seltsam oder also die
kameraführung ist nicht eigentlich so
wie sie sein sollte aber leute
fokussieren uns auf das positive bisher
hat sich noch keiner die axt selbst ins
bein gehackt bis jetzt habe alle ihre
freundinnen erkannt ich irgendwas sagt
mir aber dass der dritte ich habe
wirklich nicht gesehen dass der dritte
jetzt reist als letztes ist samir an der
reihe doch im gegensatz zu seinem
kontrahenten ist er sich noch ein wenig
unsicher
wow
der brüller bitte bitte dich rein new
york dass der rest zusammen ich habe es
ehrlich zu vergessen vom anfang okay
weil ich dachte die information ist
nicht relevant aber ihr seid doch schon
eine weile zusammen
du musst du musst doch hast du hast du
irgendeine verbindung zwischen deinem
gehirn und deinen händen du musst auch
checken wieder eine eigene freundin so
aufgebaut ist die erleichterung ist groß
auch nancy und so haben wir bekommen
einen punkt sich gern ihre figur 80.000
erkannte der typ macht einfach richtig
new york ist wirklich so latin lover
leute wenn er so ein antrag keine ahnung
beim bürgerbüro und antrag stellt darauf
dass er seinen müll ausweis bekommt
fakten sie die dame und warum sind sie
heute hier also
ich bin einfach nur hier um mir zu sagen
dass sie wirklich atemberaubende augen
haben und ihre augenbrauen die
entfernung ihre augenbrauen ist
annähernd optimal
dann sollte die nächste runde erst recht
kein problem sein denn nun müssen die
uns das hinterteil ihrer freundin
erkennen
christian nach den anfang also digger
also okay ich meine klar das ist
irgendwo interessant so also auf eine
sehr primitive art und weise zieht man
sich das auch manchmal rein wenn das
eine gen ausgeschaltet ist und so das
unterbewusstsein überhaupt nimmt aber
das hat sich ja irgendjemand nüchtern
bei vollem bewusstsein ausgedacht dieses
format willst ja also ich kann auch auf
so eine idee kommen aber nach wenn ich
betroffen bin
liebe kollegen herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen redaktions meeting ich möchte
ihnen gerne meine idee vorschlagen für
die zukünftige produktion von formaten
ich hätte gedacht wir könnten einen
videobeitrag über die nachhaltige
belastung deswegen weil das machen was
sind denn sie ihre vorschläge
wir könnten leute anfassen lassen 200
ganz wichtig für euch jetzt leute checkt
hier einfach ich vorgeschlagen das video
ab wann abonniert hier meinen kanal
sonst kommt bald ein 20 jähriger azubi
bei euch vorbei und begrapscht eure
freundin vor eurem freund ich meine
beste draus machen